Throughout the Donald Trump presidency, I
would often jokingly say whatever happened
to that migrant caravan coming to the United
States border from Mexico?
And of course, it was a joke referencing the
completely capricious and arbitrary nature
of how the Trump Republican Party and Republicans
more broadly go back to the same refrains
when it's convenient for them.
Trump had a crazy phone call with Ukraine.
Well, it's infrastructure week at the White
House.
Republicans propose an insane health care
plan that would lead to 24 million people
losing coverage while the migrant caravan
is coming and Democrats don't care.
Laura Ingraham literally ran a segment yesterday
called Joe Biden's Insurrection.
Yeah, I know Donald Trump second impeachment
trial starts today because he incited the
January 6th insurrection.
Yes, Joe Biden has a higher approval rating
already than Donald Trump ever did during
his entire presidency.
Yes, Republicans are standing in opposition
to a covid relief bill that's popular with
the majority of the country.
Yes, the majority of Americans wants Donald
Trump convicted.
So it's time for Biden's insurrection.
Let's take a look at these clips, which, as
Laura Ingram will explain to us, is Joe Biden
welcoming undocumented immigrants to the United
States?
Let's check out the clips.
Fox News apparently realizing they need to
out crazy on a Newsmax to get back some of
the audience that they've lost.
Now, that takes us back to tomorrow's Barnum
and Bailey revival in the Senate.
Democrats are arguing that Trump welcomed
and incited a violent incursion into the capital.
When it is they who are enticing illegals
to bust through our borders, exploit our resources
and commit crimes, and we're not talking about
a few hundred, we're talking hundreds of thousands,
eventually millions.
If the Democrats have their way, even for
Fox News, this is really a stretch at this
point.
I don't even know if the Fox News audience
believes this, at least not a huge portion
of it, but some of them do.
Let's listen to some more.
And she really crams in a lot of hate, xenophobia,
misdirection, red herrings into this one short
clip.
There is an insurrection taking place against
America.
All right.
It's been going on for years in the deepest
depth of the DC swamp, and now its figurehead
resides at sixteen hundred Pennsylvania Avenue.
This insurrection seeks to overthrow everything
we love about America by defaming it, silencing
it and even prosecuting it.
This is an organized mob funded by billionaires.
It's supported by celebrities, and it's aided
and abetted by propagandistic news organizations
every single step of the way.
These insurrectionists have stormed our schools
with BLM, indoctrinated us, they shuttered
our classrooms by empowering union heavies,
they've overwhelmed small businesses with
idiotic, stupid lockdowns.
They've robbed Americans of good paying oil
and gas jobs with obscene climate change dictates
they've ripped down historical markers from
Washington to Lincoln.
They've terrorized patriotic Americans who
are now afraid to just speak their minds,
they burn police precincts, they've taken
over entire city blocks, and not just for
a few hours, by the way, but for weeks.
This is the sort of brown people are going
to take your house portion of Laura Ingram's
program.
And this is actually a lot of what these faux
populists are, right wing populists, where
they sort of sound like populists, but their
solutions are bankers.
Often they end up at Black Lives Matter will
take your house, brown people will take your
job sort of stuff.
And in that short clip, Black Lives Matter
is bad.
Mexican immigrants are bad, liberal celebrities
are bad.
Covid guidelines are bad.
Getting away with fossil getting away from
fossil fuels is bad.
Climate change is fake.
Confederate monuments are good.
And it's so heavily weaponized that it's difficult
to believe that it's even real.
I mean, it looks like an SNL skit.
Of a Fox News show, if Fox News decided to
run a test where they said, let's test our
audience to see what's the dumbest and craziest
thing we can get them to believe.
How about this?
Let's pretend Joe Biden is leading an insurrection.
This is what that test would look like.
And we've seen you know, we wondered a month
ago, what would a post Trump Fox News look
like?
Fox News no longer covers covid briefings,
which are happening.
By the way, FOX News rarely covers White House
press briefings which are happening.
And it's this type of stuff now fighting for
the most extreme audience they can.
And there's a real question as to whether
they believe that that is the audience they
need to be profitable.
In other words, if what they were losing to
on a Newsmax were not a particularly profitable
piece of their audience, they wouldn't necessarily
need to be doing this to get that audience
back.
But they're doing it and there must be a reason
for it.
And of course, the really scary part is that
you and I see this.
We know every word is a lie.
It's it's like when it was the migrant caravan
during the Trump era.
Right.
It's all made up.
It's all fake.
There are millions of people in this country,
though, where you sit them down and you show
them that commentary from Laura Ingraham and
they believe it.
And they think that forget about they think
it's good reporting.
They think it's reporting rather than just
the rantings of of Laura Ingraham.
And it's a systemic problem.
And when we talk about I don't want to do
my whole rant now, but when we talk about
epistemology, when we talk about media literacy,
when we talk about identifying logical fallacies
and distinguishing between statements of fact
and statements of opinion, opinion, programing,
news, programing, all of these things, the
net effect is Laura Ingram does that.
And a lot of people come away thinking, I
have now been informed by a news report, which
is, of course, the furthest thing from what
that actually was